welcome to the biggest event in the
world of energy men live from the
Dorothy Chandler Pavilion in Los Angeles
it's the 68th Annual Academy Awards
tweeting the stars as they arrived to
celebrate Oprah Winfrey I'm here at the
Oscars it's my favorite night of the
year I watched every single year never
miss since I was 10 years old and
tonight I have the best seat in the
house along with you there's the star of
under siege in action director Steven
Seagal nominated for Best live action
short film actor Jeff Goldblum with
Oscar winner Laura Dern
it's double-oh-seven star golden eye
Pierce Brosnan Best Picture nominee for
Apollo 13 director Ron Howard giving up
the throne you're giving an epic throne
I am
hard to do was a good passing of the
torch passing a candidate or have any
prediction to know happy to give it to
whoever wins absolutely smiling at
Harrah's nominated for Best Supporting
Actor in Apollo 13 the crowds welcoming
actress Winona Ryder nominated for last
year's movie Little Women
that's right now it's a number one box
office hit now I'm drunk with power oh
excuse me I see Emma Thompson she's
nominated at Best Supporting Actress for
Sense and Sensibility Kate Winslet
nominated for Best Supporting Actor and
twelve Monkeys Brad Pitt Oscar winner
Richard Dreyfuss one of this year's Best
Actor nominees for mr. Holland's Opus
a fantastic day I can't believe it
wonderful and the other thing in the you
nominated program of course we all know
you have two major nominations here
tonight is there one in particular you
want to take home I won the boat I won
the boat
Sir Anthony Hopkins Best Actor nominee
for his portrayal in Nixon on the
Bridges of Madison County Oscar nominee
Meryl Streep she's along with her son
you're singing colors of the wind
beautiful song you need to get this in
the numbers war just really lyrical lots
of modern dance
that's a chiffon flowing I think I feel
differently singing in here on this
stage though what I think because it was
made for a movie you know it's not my
song but it's so I'm lending my creative
juices to a mix the star of what's love
got to do with it and Othello Laurence
Fishburne he saw miss Robin in Batman
Forever Chris O'Donnell
christine lottie's here a nominee for
her star and a short film Lieberman in
love
he won Best Supporting Actor last year
for Ed Wood veteran Martin Landau
to die for that's what you look like
tonight just to die for and you were to
you you're presenting
yeah yeah oh my goodness thing babe
yeah how do you feel about that picnic
oh I like that pig like Australia I
suppose you do yeah love this choice of
colors the first time I've seen it
oh thank you the star of the
generational film my family meet the
media Jimmy Smits
there's Best Supporting Actress nominee
for holo 13 Kathleen Quinlan winner of
Best Actor two years in a row Tom Hanks
with his wife Rita Wilson hi jack
hello look beautiful we wanted to see a
bit more from you yeah okay
grip the tuxedo kinda move and I know
yeah that was pretty good
thank you from the accounting firm of
Price Waterhouse which tabulates the
ballots and guarantees the secrecy and
integrity of the results Frank Johnson
and Greg garrison with his wife Kelly
Preston star up gets shorty John
Travolta Braveheart star and Best
Director nominee Mel Gibson stunning
actress Sharon Stone one of this year's
best actress nominees for casino oh my
god Elizabeth what are you
so lucky you wake up this morning and
pinch yourself yes
backpack did you ruin well I didn't
sleep at all last night so it's wide
awake
by the time you watch over you will be
briar yes yes yeah I mean everyone says
it being nominated is the thing and
there's this whole period of time from
the time you're nominated a couple
months ago until now and so how is your
life changed
um it's changed dramatically in in terms
of opportunity and changing my career
but I real-life my my love for my
husband and my family and my dog and all
the real things haven't changed
there's Susan Sarandon a Best Actress
nominee for dead man walking with her
husband Tim Robbins
ladies and gentlemen oscar-winning
actress and host of the 68th Annual
Academy Awards Whoopi Goldberg
so do you miss me
yeah
welcome to the 68th Annual Academy
Awards or as is known in certain circles
cutthroat island
I'm your host Whoopi Goldberg or as I am
known in certain circles the mighty afro
deity especially this year you know I
want to say something to all the people
who sent me ribbons to where you don't
ask a black woman to buy an expensive
dress and then cover it with ribbons
it's true you don't come borrow get out
but but I got them all so here it goes I
got a red ribbon for AIDS awareness done
I got a purple ribbon for breast cancer
done I got a yellow ribbon for the
troops in Bosnia done I got a green
ribbon to free the Chinese dissidents
done I got a milky white ribbon for mad
cow disease done I got a rainbow ribbon
but gay rights disease gun gun done
again our fake fur ribbon for animal
rights done a whit white ribbons and
white water done at sea it's like a
ribbon to let Martin Landau finish his
speech from last year done
a plaid ribbon a plan driven that Mel
Gibson wore instead of pants and
Braveheart done and a blue ribbon that
somebody swiped off babe
John enough with the ribbons is done
Jesse Jackson asked me to wear a ribbon
I got it but I had something I wanted to
say to Jesse right here but he's not
watching so why bother
but there is somebody I want to give a
ribbon to who I know is watching Alec
Baldwin Bravo baby so
it's all out of the way now it's out of
the way and I have to admit the show is
a little different this year you know
Quincy Jones is the producer honey you
know but I have to tell you he wanted to
change the title to Showtime at the
Apollo 13
I said no honey because that forces me
to say Whitney Houston we have a problem
no no whoo but the man has made some
changes because Oprah was on the
sidewalk looking for umma now
Oscar is 68 younger than Bob Dole
and I'm glad I'm glad that it looks like
Bob's going to get that nomination honey
because it means he'll be too damn busy
to go to the movies and then we have Pat
Buchanan the original boy in the hood
he had a profound influence on the
movies this year Pat's the man who
inspired the title Dangerous Minds
clueless and dumb and Dumberer and while
we're on the subject that has been a big
year for pigs babe showgirls I mean come
on all please hello what were they
thinking what come on I haven't seen
that many poles mistreated since World
War two you know
this picture proved that if you gave the
public what they want they'd stay home
and watch it on video but I must say
women's roles were interesting this year
Elisabeth Shue played a hooker Mira
Sorvino played a hooker Sharon Stone
played a hooker
how many times did Charlie Sheen gets a
vote come on come on
and it was a confusing year for me
anyway because I thought dead man
walking was the documentary about Keith
Richards I didn't know I didn't know and
there was a lot of heavy campaigning
going on for ill Postino Merrimack spent
so much money promoting it that if it
hadn't gotten the nomination they were
going to re-release it as Ilkka Postino
it was big numbers were big in titles
this year not even sequels I mean
Richard the third Apollo thirteen twelve
Monkeys seven and of course sixty bucks
the Hugh Grant story so on that note
Oscar's in the house and everybody
watching us at parties pour yourself a
serious one get your pencils ready
because we're about to start handing out
some little gold ball man who will it be
we are ill Postino or ell porky no kilts
capsules since sensibility let's get to
it with our first award and to present
it a gentle man who in his last picture
destroyed a helicopter a train a
satellite a tank and a large chunk of
Russia the picture was called Goldeneye
and his name is Brosnan Pierce Brosnan
Thank You Whoopi I have before me the
daunting task of presenting the first
award of the evening James Bond would
never venture into such an adventure
without a secret weapon and I have to
allow me to welcome introduce my
colleagues the expert in efficient
claudia schiffer and the cool and
professional Naomi Campbell
you